this is the technical difficulties of
playing citation needed joining me today
he reads books you know it's Chris Joel
or drinking coffee yet I think that
prioritize maybe everybody's favorite
going round Gary Brannen and shall the
man chase the lady I'll have another
girl but I don't reckon fit another
bread roll up my ass well now the
question is I know Gary was playing to
prep lines for this series underpanties
Marlene set my grace series 5 welcome in
front of me I've got a hard to go from
Wikipedia and these folks can't see it
every fact if everyone takes a point and
a ding and the special prize prompting
announces which is last is before you're
in for a treat every season we get new
people you oh my god for about do it can
do it let's the essay today we are
talking about the hydraulic telegraph
holy mole that's a wet telegram um I'll
give you I'll give you point there's
water involved oh yes it looks terrific
it's very tronic smell the floor or I
know nothing about science it's all piss
in witchcraft leave an idle a bit and
you're still getting the point for it
well I will go too much done stand in
front of the nozzle to receive your
message come on Mildred says hello but I
don't want to tell you what she's been
up to on that point yesterday I genuine
this is a dead news though I saw a coach
company called Moore's coaches right
that's good it was reversing I
understand why the VP noise we're just
saying s repeatedly probably just say me
the thing is we all patented your Morse
code there in different ways
mama he's up at E I'm like not T that's
a little surely good st. man and this
vehicle is reversing in Morse is what I
was thinking but people wouldn't move
out the way they'll be too busy trying
to read it committed by did this it
wasn't Morse code not the not the any
version of this plugs a little 10 Flags
awesome like many flags that would pop
up there's another message your finger
the optical Telegraph I think of an
optical Telegraph powered by Walter
thank you very much oh I'm gonna give
you a point for the lesson no no how
would you there are flags and their
water and this is first of all this when
little boxes houses you get outdoors and
do rifle tanks then also soren jizz
today we have the handle on now there
cello childress today we're learning
about things okay when I'm up flags
there's water and news and there are
internal goodbye we'll see you next week
goodbye
I don't think we clearly explained what
Tommy's though without adjectives like
u-turn Michelle running anywhere is a
some kind of coastal system for getting
messages out into the water by sending
different pressures to pop up things it
would spell out a message
yeah I'll give you the point that I
definitely view the text pop up pirate
but telega it sounds like why do you
think this was 19th century everything
was iron and hydraulic then right oops
Teddy this is not the version of it
we're talking about there is a 19th
century version again I will give you a
point but I'm gonna come to that later
is this the mid 90s version in Eureka in
Halifax Oh
I mean northern reference I wonder Civic
and when will will will when just kids
to Eureka it's
there as far as I stood I didn't know
they had a hydraulic Talon I do i but if
they don't know about a massive
Archimedes screw on the ceiling
looky Archimedes we're talking about
Archimedes we're pretty much in the
right hour so greco-roman yeah our
fourth century BC Greece Oh point trying
to imagine a fourth century Greece I'm
just gonna put grease lightning -
laughing and I'm failing badly than
there
well you can't none of us have got house
oh my god hang on oh it studied lucky
classical education been more than a
decade since I got my GCSE in Latin and
can you manage I've got chills they're
multiplying
probably not a at yes layer uh every
time read at all
probably ask frigid frigid or something
say you multi pick darkness or something
like that multi pick that assess yeah
yeah corrections in the comments for all
of you YouTube Watchers who know Latin
so ancient Greece yes there are two
signal towers on two Hills and with two
identical tubs of water how do they get
them to both show the same message
because inscriptions on the side of the
tub of water how do they get them to to
synchronize gentle and well timed pin
Ling oh I'm so totally give you a point
gentle more time horse piddling no
they're not that offering water in
gentle paddling's of villages links down
to being much peddling on the wall
they like summer up they'd like some
water out where tap or something like
yes a spigot Oh what else as if they
have virtue from the bottom of one into
the pot with the other soil also leveled
no that's the British system that comes
like this I'll give you a point but
that's not how they synchronized between
to faraway Hills
man yelling mobile phones no because it
can't be something else because the
water is the communication method or is
that storing litmus hang on we're never
actually established at this waters any
method of communication the minute we
just have two towers that let some water
occasion yeah and there's those things
inscribed on little bowls okay where the
water comes out so how do you get both
sides to time when they're taking the
plug out and putting it back it lights
fourth century BC candles um it's a big
candle fire bonfire
here we go these okay anyway candid ones
gone girl why the worth they lit fires
anyway because a bonfire can only send
one signal I'm on fire it's out to me it
can send two signals I'm not on fire
that's true on and off yep or downtown
in it
Highbury Oh unplug off put it back in
what's the message you both read down
your balls ball says I'm on fire yeah
must be a big bowl
they said done an earthenware Bowl of
depth being some three cubits yeah yeah
oh yes absolutely have a point I was
getting on look up cubed yeah but that's
something roughly right you got two done
so to those my cubit so yeah it's about
about yay big
and presumably draining quite slowly
selected synchro sorry please send chips
or whatever the great equivalent
embodies pizza yeah half when I want to
adjust that laughing and crying emoji
drama
smiling poo it's halfway between ruffle
and loll I don't know where we are
oh it's sort of sitting on the floor
rocking back and forth a bit it's like
anything where you use a little you see
it reached law on the watermark you look
over he's just out there doing that game
taking crap you you just see I don't
know why I had this ancient Greek man
looking at his phone cuz that's what
they usually communicate I've said lot
Lalas fallen out of fashion now though
it is it is just emojis now people don't
type love as much the amount but it was
kind of things isn't it where people
aren't used to emojis yet keep using
that laughing and crying one yeah for
actual crying yeah which changes the
tone of a message like I'm sorry you're
unstudied
and then of the clock crying with
laughter emoji my my sites like the
parents who thought Lowell meant lots of
love yes that happened yeah yeah so he
broke it uncle Paul but that's like MSN
Messenger balls remember MSN Messenger
de nowhere don't somewhere too young for
it it was like facebook messenger only
you would wear tall night for your
friend to appear and there may not so
there was an idea as I think you said
British 19th century years for two
connected tombs you I don't know what
side like this friendly um and the idea
was you would put in water or take out
water and it would synchronize at the
other side what were some of the
problems with that system putting the
tubing in the first place
yeah I'll give you a point it's 200 quid
a mile which in 1838 money is a lot of
money about just sending a messenger
well I would've had to be made out a
copper or something expensive
Roy yeah just PVC to you from wicks yeah
that's I am was often you for hydraulic
choose because the container pressure I
had what distance are we talking are we
talking like over a dock or over London
because London was basically
hydraulically powered up until the
nineteen twenties well that's true
looking at a big hydropower system and
so if it's overlooking you should you
should explain how that worked but he's
faxing accumulator so big towers it
would be used to store the pressure and
it would be used for moving lifts for
goods left for cranes it will be powered
off the central hydraulic power system
will with pipes on the London they're
still still definitely use deserve cable
runs now hmm under London looks it was a
huge London Weiss's especially using the
docks at gates and crayons but then
lifts and other things that need
powering left and Hillier and yarn like
dumbwaiters in hotels they just are
massive water tank at the centre of the
system that were able to get created the
pressure that gets pumped through and
you can use some pressure if you wanted
yeah the love of God will somebody
biscuits that man
this is the season um yes
that was part of the problem the the
inventor was mr. Francis wisher of
course a good Victoria inventors name um
no sooner is motion given to one end a
reader's though this is communicated
through the whole sixty yards to the
other end door so you might as well wave
that's what I said distance was the
problem you could just yell but when you
said hydraulic Telegraph where I was
forgetting the hydraulic met water mmm
but remember bed it was tubes of stuff I
was thinking of the the the stem I'm
good mine tell me about your MA
the blowy tubes they had vacuum tubes
yes
sorry sucky tubes pneumatic - pneumatic
is the right one they had our system of
Telegraph through yeah you just had
known you can't you had one you got a
tube with a hair going on my hair going
Ellen you put up it still you all around
London hmm yes there was atmospheric
trains as well there was a hole that was
a hobby sorry where I'm powering things
was Hyperloop and I don't know what that
is is no Hyperloop is magnetic induction
but it's inside a vacuum inside a vacuum
what is we just a vacuum you just it has
like a tube carriage with like a shield
round in the middle that would act as a
piston and you would just put them in
and sure you you're basically release
air at one end yeah and you'd be just
sucked through in a tube carriage and
then you just appeared the other end
hoping that you will you would be in it
in the container you'll really get rain
here it's not peaceful you it's not the
thing foggy drama at the same time on
that you'd be hoping no longer window
for a [ __ ] it's nothing like the end the
Goldfinger on me on the ground and but
their world or above ground atmospheric
trains as well because you'd have a big
pneumatic tube of the middle of the
lines again with a piston underneath
that would suck the train long but the
problem was just loving all these hand
actions what you would have is that they
use some kind of course
on the rubber and it was really
attractive to rats so they ate it and
the entire Asia back I'm probably the
rats would at some point get smeared
into the wall by her actually and the
runs at you know get full of imploded
coke imploded rats and they might even
lubricate the system Oh briefly here
visually as they disintegrate here so
the hydraulic Telegraph what were what
were the other problems we have a
distance not being particularly good
cast
we have cost yeah what's the other
problem if you've got you've got water
the needs to be kept level between two
science water always find its own level
all right okay so you need to places
that are at the same height for it to
balance out properly yes you can do it
from top of it all to the bottom of a
hill no because otherwise it would just
follow a smelly boy you've invented
there is a fountain Oh comes out water's
right actually personally okay your
water's my communication water is the
best way to transmit a message the
British are attacking what you have to
do Paul Revere's you have to start on
top of this hill go down the slide once
if by land and twice it by see what hang
on you're going back up again
- different gods his towel have you done
kyuri buffs away doctor comes down again
with no idea I'm going it's good not
four times now he's just being greedy
its message appears to be we please I'm
just seeing stuff like the d-day
landings with soldiers coming up little
slides off in the bus we when that may
wash so much more jolly woman's a lot of
ways to make war more jolly yeah I think
like not doing it yeah you're not
killing people we start sending the
jesters mm machine gun is fired up
serial flags they just set back at the
end of the show then congratulations
Gary you win this week you win an
intimate waxing by a legendary six-time
Grammy winning American composer
go on it's the Burt Bacharach back crack
in the sack
so congratulations with that we say
thank you to Chris Cole Oh - Gary
Brannen and macro goodbye you too I've
been Tom Scott we'll see you next time
you